Here Putin is today.
So he
met with the chairman of what's
called the Russian Constitutional Court.
And this man pulls out a map
from the 17th century
to show Putin
and to make a very specific point
about Ukraine.
Just listen to it for yourself.
Nicholas, who appeared in court.
We found a copy of a map
from the 17th century
created during the time of Louis,
the 14th in the middle of the 17th.
In the second half of the 17th century,
created by the French themselves.
Why did I bring it
Vladimir Vladimirovich.
It has no Ukraine.
Because it was,
of course, Soviet rule
created Soviet Ukraine.
It is a well-known fact.
No, Ukraine
existed in the history
of humankind until then.
Well, you go back to the time of Louis
14th, of course.
Gosh, you can go further and see
he was the founder of Moscow.
You get the point.
That's the absurdity that Putin was was
wanted today.
Fred Pleitgen
and Matthew Chance are both standing
by with new reporting on OUTFRONT.
I want to begin first, though,
with you in Kiev, Fred,
because you're hearing
about a new explosion in
Belgrade tonight.
You're absolutely right, Erin.
And while Vladimir
Putin seems to indicate
there used to be no Ukraine, certainly
right now
the Russians seem to be feeling the heat,
at least it appears
from Ukraine, in fact, right now.
Just a couple of minutes ago,
the governor of that Belgorod
region, who you were talking about,
who was criticizing
the Russian military,
he said that there had been
another possible strike
by a drone in the Belgorod region
and that some sort of munition
was dropped on a roadway
and damaged a car there.
Of course,
that's something
that we've seen several times
over the past couple of days.
Also, in light of those incursions
that have been happening
and despite the fact that,
as Matthew has been reporting
and we've been reporting,
those are Russians
who are going into Ukrainian territory.
So it's Russians against Russians.
The Russian government
in the form of Dmitry Peskov,
the spokesman for Vladimir
Putin, is trying to pin this
on the Ukrainians.
He says today
that he believes
this all shows
that Russia is under attack from Ukraine
and that therefore
Russia's war against
Ukraine is justified now.
I also asked
the national security
adviser of Ukraine
whether or not the Ukrainians are afraid
that there could be massive retaliation
from the Russians after this,
perhaps another massive missile strike.
And he said, look,
the Russians are already striking us
almost every day.
They've hit us
with more than 1400 missiles already.
What else is going to come?
And at the same time, of course, Erin,
the Ukrainians are also preparing
for that big counter offensive.
And I asked him where that stands.
Here's what he had to say,
which, of course,
we are
clearly aware of when, where,
how and what should start.
The final decision is up to the president
and the security staff
when the decision is made.
Russia will definitely feel it,
which will
And of course, one of the things
that we also have to talk about, Erin,
and this is very important
in that context,
is the situation in Bermuda
where the Russians, of course, had
said they took the entire city
National security adviser
also telling me
that that is not true,
that the Ukraine
still have troops in the city.
He also said that the fact
that the Ukrainians
are still holding out in Bermuda
and trying to strike back
is also a key factor in the Ukrainians
being able to prepare
for that counteroffensive.
That,
of course, could happen at any time Erin.
All right.
Thank you very much, Fred, in Kiev.